what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with the really the new
mutants but continuing our x-win
coverage getting all caught up this is
the return of the shadow king now there
are a few things we need to kind of
discuss as we go through this first and
foremost there are some plot threads
that kind of go through this but truth
to tell there's only really a major
focus involving the shadow king and
cosmar as well as a few other people i
mean we'll talk about them where we'll
cross those bridges once we get to them
but for the most part i feel like those
are the really important things but this
initially picks up with us basically
joining amal farook when he was a little
kid and this is something that we
haven't seen before for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with the shadow
king we do kind of get a little bit of
explanation from marvel comics largely
in like the marvel encyclopedia you do
get a little bit of references or at
least a few references here and there
but by and large the shadow king is
considered to be a multiversal force of
energy that represents the dark nature
of humanity more so than that the only
time or really the earliest indication
we ever saw of the shadow king was when
he was bonded to amal farooq and the way
it was explained at the time is that
they were two separate things right amol
farouk was an actual person the shadow
king was an entity bonded to him but we
never really knew anything before that
we simply just knew that that's when
xavier met the shadow king xavier won
the shadow king was defeated and then
that's what really gave xavier the idea
for launching the x-men in the first
place and so what this tells us is that
in this really 16th century uh egypt
that amal farook is again just kind of
living here as a little kid right and
his father is an exceedingly proud
father and the reason why is because
amal farook has the gift of telepathy
right that's the power that he has a
very high order of telepathy and we
already knew that of course given the
battle the the nature of the conflict
between
amal farook and charles xavier from the
old x-men comics but instead of using
his powers for evil he would actually
use them for good and so because the
market was a very lively place of course
that would attract thieves people who
were looking to attain something without
actually having to work for it and so
what it did is it actually allowed them
all for roof to basically operate as a
protector in this particular instance
somebody snatches up the goods belonging
to a woman who in turn is basically
forced to return those goods by amal
farook himself the big issue here though
is that eventually illness comes to
egypt right plague comes to egypt and
that takes his father it kills his
father in his struggling and his
suffering his pain and his anguish
that's when he's visited by the shadow
king now that's one thing to understand
the shadow king visits individuals when
they're at their absolute weakest points
because that's when it's the easiest way
to break them or that's the easiest way
to kind of slither yourself in because
the shadow king is nothing if not
absolutely cunning and because amal
farouk had felt such pain and anguish
and because in his heart was really a
desire to do good what the shadow king
did is it approached him with a
perspective of we can turn this place
into a spot where people can be safe
where everyone can be okay you know i
can promise you adventure and different
things like that and in that desperation
amal farooq turned to the shadow king
and allowed the shadow king to possess
him and so that really is and this is
what's interesting this is the first
real origin that we've gotten in marvel
comics belonging to amal farook or the
shadow king if you want to kind of get
sort of them the same thing for the
purposes of this video i'm going to use
the phrase amal farooq and shadow king
interchangeably they are by and large
the same thing right they've just been
bonded together for so long that they're
basically the same thing right it's the
same concept that may change at a future
point in time but the important thing
here is that what we end up doing is
basically joining up with the new
mutants as they're training a younger
team of mutants and the reason for this
is it's really a couple different places
one is the nature of new mutants and two
it's just practicality the nature of the
new mutants is basically a publishing
initiative for those of you guys who
don't know that back in the 80s the idea
of marvel is that they should simply
just launch a teenage superhero team
that's predicated on one the
incontinuity idea that the x-men were
dead and two that you know when the
x-men do return because we knew they
would then eventually they would kind of
graduate and go off to do their own
thing and so having the new mutants line
is kind of a roster of younger mutants
who were trained by xavier that would go
on to replace the x-men as those various
individuals left kind of created this
cycle right the characters or people
would be brought into the new mutants
and those new mutants would graduate to
basically take the roles of the x-men
who leave and the cycle would just kind
of go on and on and on seemingly forever
and so the way that works in krakowa is
that whenever you have these little kids
who are either born or they're abandoned
by their parents or whatever the case is
that because krakowa needs forces to
basically protect krakowa itself as well
as keep this idea of kokoa having what
is in effect a military that while these
kids aren't necessarily thrown into
combat right off the bat that they are
trained by new mutants who are basically
overseen by ileana rasputin magic and
largely because she's the best person to
do this i mean everybody else here has a
lot of experience right wolfsbane and
danny moonstar and all these guys they
all have a lot of experience here but
the important thing is that when it
really when it comes down to it in terms
of just having been around the block
more than a few times that's really
ileana rasputin right i mean she was
quite literally trapped in limbo a
hellish dimension for a pretty lengthy
amount of time right she is really the
closest that you have here to a
full-fledged x-man basically helping the
team i mean she is an x-man by all
standards of measurement but what they
talk about here is the idea of synergy i
hate the phrase of synergy right it's a
phrase used by just corporate people and
it just it makes a person sound like a
douchebag when they say it but what
they're doing here is basically saying
as a team right when you become part of
the new mutants you have to understand
the powers of your teammates inside and
out it almost has to be instinctive you
have to know that when you're facing off
against various threats that if you
understand the powers of your teammates
correctly you could have them come in
and take your place as you fight
somebody else and they fight the person
that you were fighting right you have to
work as a seamless unit and that's what
happens here right you actually end up
having the new mutants facing off
against themselves and their their
ability to just work in unison is
uncanny it's it's incredible it's really
up there on par with uh with the x-men
themselves now during this whole
escapade this whole series of events you
have a girl named cosmart now cosmo has
a one-shot origin that we can cover if
you guys are interested i don't even
know if it's really a one-shot so much
as like three or four pages but the
thing about this is she is basically a
character with reality warping but
before you guys oh another reality
whatever mutant
the the thing about her powers is she
can only do it one in an exceedingly
localized space and two she basically
manifests her nightmares but it's really
in the form of a bubble so if you're
like 20 feet away from her you'll just
kind of see her sitting there just
freaking out but if you get close enough
she can either telepathically pull you
in or physically pull you in and you'll
experience nightmares as well right it's
a pretty potent ability and in all
honesty depending on what direction
marvel goes with it she could be
absurdly powerful at the very least
enough to just absolutely mentally
destroy other people who were out there
the other part of this is gabby now
gabby for those of you guys who are
pretty new here she's basically the
clone of laura kinney who isn't turn a
clone of wolverine but initially it was
believed that she was going to become
just some kind of crazy villain not
necessarily instead she actually became
a pretty cool member of the wolverine
mythos with laura kinney the biggest
issue here is she's kind of an outlier
to a degree now a lot of this is because
gabby looks so normal and the other kids
who are here look so abnormal they don't
really have a sort of common ground in
that way the the kind of explanation
given here right by by ileana rasputin
is that in time that'll change but these
younger mutants actually end up leaving
and traveling to a location only for us
to find out they're meeting up with the
shadow king now this is one of the cool
things about this right amal farook
approaches them as what is basically a
kind of mentor right and basically
saying like i am here to help you guys
learn more about your abilities to help
you guys train now that's the thing
whenever you see the shadow king and you
see a situation like this the shadow
king is usually nefarious and so when
you see him having dealings with a bunch
of very young and very inexperienced
mutants your initial response is oh my
god he's going to turn them into his
personal army
which is most likely what would actually
happen the funny thing about this is
that it's actually not right that's
really not what's going to happen here
instead things are going to get really
really intriguing and so what you end up
doing here is basically picking up with
rain sinclair now the reason why this is
important is because wolfsbane has had a
very very troubled history over the
course of her life if it is a form of
abuse she has been through it right just
one because of her physical appearance
and two because there was a point in
marvel when she just kind of found
herself bouncing around from one
location to the next she's been used for
demonic possession she's been used by
godly entities literally her life is
nothing more than just pain and
suffering and where in x-men vol 5 or
really uncanny x-men vol 5 she was
actually beat to death because she
wouldn't defend herself against humans
who realized that she was a mutant when
she was resurrected of course a lot of
those memories were returned to her and
so for the most part even though she's
back she still remembers all that pain
and suffering that she's experienced
over the course of her life and that's
kind of an important thing here right
not the most important thing but it
really is something worth mentioning
because with this girl in particular
she's gonna play somewhat of a
significant role but beyond that cosmar
much in the same way suffers the way
reign sinclair does the difference is
that of course as you guys can tell
kosmar's physical mutation is far more
extreme and even then as you see all
this stuff going on right amal farooq
who's basically at this big party
because again the x-men know he's there
right it's not as though he's inhabiting
the island and no one's aware of his
existence everyone knows he's there but
you see everybody partying you see
everybody having a good time everybody's
celebrating for cosmar it doesn't work
for her that way and the reason why is
because one she's 13 right what 13 year
old do you know who has it together no
13 year old has it together
they're just they're just now getting
into that part of their life when like
hormones start running awry and
everything is a big deal right like
everything that happens is the biggest
thing to happen ever but the thing about
this is that for for cosmo because of
her physical mutation and because of the
fact that her parents actually ended up
dying as a result of her powers
manifesting she sees herself as as
something horrible right some kind of
diseased ugly hideous creature and so
when the entire group goes back together
or comes back together again and they
meet up with them all for rook to
basically train in secret again amalfa
root does something different instead
what he does is he kind of tells them
look the nature of the new mutants
training you is that they're trying to
teach you to learn the powers of others
but you can never truly experience this
until you've walked in somebody else's
shoes of course that's both literal and
metaphorical in the sense that what he
does is he swaps minds is he actually
basically swaps all their consciousness
so they end up taking the bodies of
other individual people and in doing
that what it does is it has a pretty
massive impact on their physical forms
right has a kind of impact on their
bodies in the sense that like they kind
of feel like they're dying to a degree
but really gabby's the only one that
seems to feel that way instead once
everything kind of snaps back to normal
just due to the fact that they didn't
really expect it to uh to go that way
you know the fact that gabby's not
really able to control the powers of
cosmo and quite literally just kind of
starts expanding these powers out to the
point that it's actually a danger and
then of course amal farook sets
everything back to normal that it's one
of these things where everybody was kind
of celebrating the idea that they had
everybody else's powers now there's
merit to this right this is actually a
very very smart idea taking the
consciousness of one person and putting
it in the body of another force them to
basically swap places and then making
those individuals live out the lives or
at least some semblance of what it feels
like to be the other person it's the
only true empathy you can actually feel
right everything beyond that is just
quite literally haphazard guessing and
hoping that you get it right but gabby
lashes out at it right gabby is you know
exceedingly angry about the fact that
this whole thing happened that they
should have been worn beforehand and the
responsible mall for rook is even if
your physical body died you could be
resurrected but gabby takes that
personally and the reason why is because
while she does have a healing factor and
she can survive most anything that a lot
of these other new mutants or these
these younger mutants here cannot
survive her response is just because we
can be resurrected does not mean that
our life is cheap or worthless but the
reality is that it kind of does it would
be different if they were resurrected
and they would never have any memory of
their life before they died but the fact
that they can be resurrected and the
fact that they can be given the memories
of the life that they had before they
ended up dying and possibly even
remember what it was like to die does
kind of mean that their life is cheap
because death doesn't really have any
meaning right it doesn't really matter
to them anymore it's like dying and
being reincarnated over and over and
over again at what point does dying
matter to you right i mean
if you were immortal what value would
death have to you right you would treat
your life as cheap and you would treat
your life as being worthless not in this
sense of how you engage in the things
that you do but in the sense that the
the sanctity of life would largely
become irrelevant to you as time went on
because you would lose the feeling of
what it means or even the fear of what
it means to actually die so the reality
of this is amal for rook's kind of right
when he says like your life is largely
cheap and worthless or at least when
gabby deduces that because it kind of is
right it doesn't mean they don't matter
it silly just means death doesn't matter
and if death doesn't matter why does it
matter if you die if you're always going
to come back and so that's kind of a
crazy thing because it's really one of
these instances where gabby largely
operating under the name scout just kind
of you know really displays this lack of
trust towards amal farooq and so this is
when we get to this segment about how
rain sinclair is going to play a pretty
significant moment in this right and the
reason why is because rain sinclair has
just constantly been haunted by these
memories and these experiences that
she's been coping with since she got
back now in truth danny has been trying
to help her as best she can and really a
lot of the other mutants out there that
are struggling in the same way but the
healing gardens can't fix this right i
mean i guess maybe you could wipe these
memories away but the funny thing about
this is that amal farook approaches her
really in a kind of mentor capacity and
he says look i get that you're
experiencing terrible things you've had
horrible things happen to you over the
course of your life and he says so have
i right he's like my father was my
entire world and i lost him when i
needed him the most and he says i was
left all alone in the dark and the
shadows had teeth and so it's one of
those things where amal fruit basically
says i've been where you are right i've
been where you are before but you have
to understand life can be painful life
can be hard life can absolutely crush
your spirits in ways that you cannot
conceivably imagine but the true test of
you as a human being is are you going to
simply just give up or are you going to
be somebody who does something right
doing things changes things doing
nothing keeps things exactly as they are
and just laying there and letting life
happen to you is doing nothing right how
could you possibly ever hope for your
life to change if you do nothing to make
it change right no one's gonna come
along and save your life for you no
one's gonna come along and fix your life
for you you have to do that on your own
they got their own problems to worry
about they got their own life to live
right i mean it's one of the things
where he says if you're the person who's
just sitting around waking waiting for
someone to come along and to save your
life for you that's not going to happen
that's never going to happen right are
you a person of character and conviction
or are you weak and so that's when he
basically says when we came to krakowa
we were told that this was a land of
change by submitting to the laws of this
land we would be remade and reborn into
our truth we would be made unified whole
and together we would march into the
future kokoa is for all mutants
regardless of who we have been and what
we have done i have taken the mission of
our new home to heart i believe that we
must now live to fully realize ourselves
and that must be achieved together we
must help each other i am a psychic
creature the anguish you're experiencing
is sending sharp ripples throughout the
island and you are not the only one and
that's the great thing about this is
because when he tells her this he's not
really referencing you know people out
there who were sending psychic ripples
throughout the land i mean to a degree
they kind of are but the younger mutants
that amal farook has been training are
mutants that struggle they struggle with
their powers they struggle with their
identities they struggle with their
self-worth they struggle with seeing
themselves as anything that matters and
even rayne sinclair asked that when she
asked like what do you mean he says
there are others here children who cry
out with their minds much like i once
did i'm doing my best to help them but i
sense in you someone who has an
understanding for what they need in a
way that i do not i was the child never
the parent and what came for me i would
rather it be you and so she asks you
think i can help them as damaged as i am
and the response of a moth farouk is it
is your experience that makes you the
most fit to help and i hope that in
doing so your own wounds will begin to
heal that is hugely important here and
the cool thing about this is that with
him having this conversation with rain
sinclair what he's saying is these
experiences you've had over the course
of your life these things have that have
tormented you losing your child the
whole nine yards all these things that
you have gone through can make you
stronger all you have to do is use them
as a means to make you stronger as
opposed to letting them be a thing that
keeps you weak so use these experiences
become better become stronger and
there's truth in that right there's
absolute truth in that and so what you
end up doing is basically having gabby
basically meet up with a lot of these
younger mutants who are here and the
reason why is because they're currently
in a place called the boneyard and the
boneyard is really kind of like the body
farm right it's where people's bodies go
when they're basically dead before
they've been resurrected and so the idea
is that these individuals because these
mutants have experienced body swaps
they're actually looking to achieve that
here to take over the bodies of other
mutants because it would make them feel
normal now in truth it looks like
they're kind of misinterpreting what it
is that amal farouk was trying to teach
them but that's their line of logic as
as gabby interrupts them and realizes
what they're doing she kind of
interprets this as being like this is
what amal farouk wants you to do right
take the bodies of other people and so
on and so forth and that's what she says
like no no you cannot swap bodies like
this right you can't do that like you're
desecrating the bodies of people who
have passed away more so than that
you're being used i've been used i'm the
person who's been used and manipulated
and tricked and deceived i've been that
individual over the course of my life
and what i see happening here with amal
farooq is exactly it right she says like
what is he preparing you for right she
says shadow king is using you he's
convinced that he's the only one you can
trust and you're doing things that you
would have hated even a few weeks ago
and for what what did he promise and he
can solve all your problems if you just
do all this stuff that even you think is
not good and she says he's a liar and
that's when cosmo freaks out and that's
really the grip that the shadow king
gets on people is that cosmo loses her
mind and starts going off on gabby
because she says you don't know what
you're talking about you don't know what
you don't know what it's like you don't
know what it's like to to have have
killed your parents when your power is
manifested you don't know what it's like
to look so physically grotesque to look
so horrible right like we didn't choose
to be the people that we are we didn't
choose the powers that were given to us
and we didn't choose the way we look as
a result of the powers we have but what
a mall for rook has given us is a chance
to choose how we want to look what we
want to be like going forward and so
again it doesn't really sway gabby but
nonetheless cosmar says all i want to be
is me again and everyone treats me as if
i'm ungrateful they keep saying that
being a mutant is a gift but my whole
life was ripped away by it right i'm
thankful that gracoa has welcomed me but
i can never go home i never asked for
any of this i can't even look in the
mirror anymore what looks back is an
alien warped and wrong i just want to be
me again why is that wrong and that's
when gabby tells her there's nothing
wrong for you feeling the way that you
feel and it's it's this incredible
exchange right she says there's there's
nothing wrong with being angry and sad
about what you lost i know what that's
like i don't even have a birthday but
that doesn't mean you should ignore
what's going on the shadow king doesn't
care about any of you that you're gonna
get hurt because of him even if you
can't see that now i don't want that to
happen to you and so it's a really
really cool exchange here because
gabby's approaching this from the
perspective of of concern about what's
taking place here but cosmar and really
these other mutants here is an act of
desperation the shadow king came along
at the right time told them what they
wanted to hear in a way that basically
worked but the statement that that that
rain sinclair makes once she shows up is
when she asks what's going on the
statement given to her is that well you
know gabby's sticking her nose and and
belong to her right she doesn't have any
business of her own to mind so she's
mine in our business uh and ultimately
gabby's like no it's not like that right
like i'm just here to make sure that my
friends are okay because i care about
you guys and so that's when rayne says
look i get where you're coming from or i
get where you're saying if this is a
legitimate concern you have then you got
to bring it to the shadow king come talk
to him directly right tell him what you
think is going on tell him why you don't
trust him why you think things are a
little shady and so ultimately you
basically have you know uh rain sinclair
and gabby who show up the shadow king
welcomes them and then he says what
brings you so far off the path tonight
right now the response is you have a
right to know your fears but if there's
going to be a solution the shadow king
has the right to hear them and so
ultimately rain sinclair leaves gabby
alone and says i'll leave you to it
right she leaves gabby in the presence
of one of the most powerful evil psychic
entities in the history of marvel comics
and so he says you have misgivings
regarding my mentoring of your friends
and he says why don't we talk right and
the response of gabby and probably one
of the most foolish responses she could
possibly make is you don't scare me and
i won't let you mess with my friends
anymore let me tell you something man if
the shadow king doesn't scare you it's
because you're an idiot or because you
don't fully know what you're dealing
with but gabby will find out with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace